over the past five decades nuclear power
has prevented the release of 50 gigatons
of carbon dioxide that's equivalent to
two years of total Global energy
generation related emissions nuclear
power is the most powerful tool at our
disposal to stop human-driven climate
change in its tracks yet powerful
industrial countries like Germany have
turned their back on this technology
rapidly deactivating power plants
prematurely nuclear power despite its
clear climate change fighting potential
carries inherent risks that have
hampered political will to invest in the
technology in order to thrive and help
our planet overcome its greatest
challenge nuclear power needs to evolve
this is the future of nuclear power
we can't begin to address the solutions
of the future without addressing the
failures of the past many of the most
notorious nuclear meltdowns were caused
by errors in coolant systems take the
Three Mile Island partial meltdown
incident of 1979. the incident began
with a mechanical failure in the plant's
cooling system it all started when the
steam generators stopped receiving water
due to a faulty clogged filter the loss
of water meant that the reactor's energy
didn't have anywhere to go raising the
temperature of the reactor as the
pressure Rose due to the water being
boiled a relief valve opened a valve
designed to only open for 10 seconds but
another fault resulted in the valve
staying open allowing the precious
coolant inside the reactor to escape
pushing temperatures even higher as the
core temperature continued to rise the
reactor operators received conflicting
information from the control room the
emergency water system that should
provide extra water to the chorus was
blocked two days earlier the plant was
closed due to maintenance and the valves
from the emergency coolant were closed
Unfortunately they were not reopened
when the reactor was restarted the
operator should have noticed that these
valves were closed but for unknown
reasons he didn't see the warning lights
on his control panel one leading theory
is that his stomach blocked his view of
the control panel even then the NRC the
regulatory body governing nuclear safety
had a rule that if the emergency coolant
valves were closed the reactor must be
shut down the situation at Three Mile
Island was in clear violation of those
rules while the Meltdown was triggered
by a mechanical failure the situation
was worsened by human error The Three
Mile Island incident serves as a
reminder of the critical importance of
both robust mechanical Safety Systems
and foolproof controls in nuclear power
plants it highlights the need for
attention to detail in design where even
minor aspects like the positioning of
alarms on control panels can have
far-reaching consequences potentially
leading to catastrophic meltdowns to
prevent such incidents future nuclear
power plant designs was proactively
addressed these issues when the
consequence of human error are nuclear
meltdowns there is no room for human
error in Fukushima an earthquake and its
resulting tsunami knocked out the
plant's cooling systems the cooling
systems in Fukushima depended on a
separate energy source the pumps that
were needed to cool the reactors lost
power resulting in a catastrophic
meltdown the plant did have a backup
system which also failed this need for
external power to cool the reactors was
a key disadvantage of this design
Fukushima also highlighted a weakness of
current nuclear reactors the use of
water as a coolant liquid water is a
great conductor of heat and serves as a
fantastic cooling agent however when
control is lost this water can lead to
high pressure steam explosions spreading
radioactive materials across vast
distances for this reason many new
reactor designs seek to incorporate
passive cooling systems which require no
external power source and aim to replace
water with safer cooling mediums before
discussing these future designs there is
another large problem facing nuclear
energy its waste light water reactors
operate in what is called an open fuel
cycle in this cycle the uranium gets
mined processed enriched used and then
stored leaving us with barrels of
radioactive waste that governments have
been struggling to deal with in the U.S
there have been plans to create deep
geological storage facilities 660 meters
below Yucca Mountain this has been the
plan since the 1980s but hasn't been put
into action so nuclear fuel is being
stored in dangerous interim storage
facilities scattered around the country
as is the case with most nuclear energy
projects it has faced delays and a lack
of funding Obama Trump and Biden have
all failed to address this looming
ecological threat waste management
issues have continually caused political
turmoil shipments of nuclear waste from
France to Germany have been met with
thousands of protesters a key driver of
political pushback on the development of
nuclear energy so is there an
engineering solution to this logistical
concern of course adequate long-term
storage is possible Sweden has approved
large storage repositories here in
frostmack Finland has made similar
arrangements to store its nuclear waste
here this finished deep geological
repository is expected to come online
within a year deep geological
repositories are sophisticated
engineered systems that employ multiple
layers of protective barriers to isolate
the spent fuel from the surrounding
environment what if we could make use of
this nuclear waste rather than locking
it away for centuries like some sort of
Supernatural Zelda villain nuclear waste
can be recycled during the early
development of nuclear power uranium was
taught to be a limited resource so a lot
of research was directed into creating
closed fuel Cycles where they spent
uranium would be reprocessed and
recycled but the Assumption of limited
uranium was wrong uranium is very common
in the Earth's crust it's much cheaper
to mine enrich and process uranium than
it is to recycle nuclear waste into
workable fuel hence the adoption of the
open fuel cycle this is the system
currently operating on most nuclear
reactors with new waste piling up every
minute
recycling spent nuclear fuel is just a
matter of separating unused uranium from
the fission products this process is not
new it was developed in the 1950s and
the basic steps are still used today in
France and in Japan
France for example cools its nuclear
waste here for three years it sits there
before moving to the reprocessing steps
with the added cost and the potential of
extracting plutonium for nuclear weapons
the counter Administration banned U.S
recycling facilities in 1977. this
recycled fuel can go back into regular
light water reactors or it could go into
newer reactor designs two common themes
in New Generation reactors is passive
Cooling and high thermal efficiencies
through high temperature coolants light
water reactors are limited to operating
at around 300 degrees Celsius Above This
temperature the high pressure water
begins to boil thermal efficiency is how
much electrical energy we can produce
from thermal energy and in general this
efficiency gets better with higher
temperatures to increase efficiency
future nuclear reactors can switch the
coolant to something that can handle
higher temperatures in the early 2000s
the US Department of energy decided to
create the Gen 4 International Forum it
was composed of the best scientists from
around the world to direct policy
decisions and funding for new reactor
designs they chose a total of six new
reactor Technologies and coined them
Generation 4 reactors instead of using
water as a coolant Gen 4 reactors can
use gas supercritical water molten salts
molten lead or sodium to increase the
operating temperature of the reactor
this increase in efficiency will result
in less nuclear wastes per gigawatt
generated but these designs also aim to
increase passive cooling capabilities
and limit nuclear proliferation risks
one of the most interesting prospects is
the molten salt reactor or MSR in these
reactors the coolant and the radioactive
fissile material are all combined the
basic premise of these reactors was
tested and experimented with during the
1960s at the Oak Ridge National
Laboratory in a molten salt reactor the
fuel consists of nuclear fuel such as
uranium or thorium dissolved in a molten
salt mixture the salts typically use
their fluorides or chlorides which have
high melting points and good heat
transfer properties the fuel salt
circulates through the Reactor Core
absorbing heat generated by the nuclear
fission after it passes through the core
the fuel salt transfers heat to a
secondary salt coolant Loop the
secondary Loop which does not contain
fissile material absorbs the heat from
the fuel salt and carries it to the heat
exchanger in the heat exchanger the heat
from the secondary salt is transferred
to a separate working fluid typically
water which then Powers a steam
generator since the coolant they use
does not need to be at high pressure
like the water cooled reactors in
Fukushima salt reactors are not risk of
high temperature steam explosions while
light water reactors typically have a
thermal efficiency of around 30 percent
molten salt reactors have been theorized
to achieve efficiencies between 40 to 45
percent molten salt reactors also have
the potential for inline fuel processing
which means that while the reactor is
operating the fuel salt can be
continuously reprocessed to remove
fission products and add new fuel
meaning the machine can run continuously
without stopping for refueling at first
glance you'll notice that the system
needs not one but two pumps however
these reactors can safely cool down even
when power is lost to these pumps the
salt's chemical properties naturally
inhibit further nuclear fission as
temperatures increase the exact
mechanisms of this depend on the salt's
composition but generally as the molten
salt gets hotter it expands this
expansion decreases the volume of fuel
in the core of the reactors and
therefore decreases the rate of nuclear
fission meaning the hotter it gets the
less fission occurs helping prevent
nuclear meltdown a freeze plug is also
located at the bottom of the liquid salt
pool the freeze plug is designed to melt
at a particular temperature in the event
of an uncontrolled rise in temperature
the plug will melt and allow the fuel
and molten salt to passively drain into
cooled dump tanks molten salt reactors
are some time away from commercial
Readiness and that problem extends to
all other fourth generation reactors
despite significant support from
proponents of these Technologies the
fourth generation International Forum
originally proposed that most of these
Technologies would be ready by 2020 but
based on the fact that the only footage
available is from the 1960s that has not
come to fruition lack of funding and
competition from low-cost solar and wind
has held back development of these
fourth generation Technologies this
problem is only going to continue until
nuclear energy addresses its largest
problem cost since 2003 MIT has been
conducting studies specifically aimed at
guiding researchers and policy makers
towards a viable future for nuclear
energy in their latest report they
stated that the utmost importance must
be given to lowering the cost of nuclear
plants and thus the most promising idea
is seek to address these cost issues
while deep geological repositories
uranium reprocessing and Gen 4 reactors
had the brunt of work done during the
1900s a new design concept started to
emerge in the early 2000s small modular
reactors or smrs for Shores the goal of
this design is to miniaturize reactors
and convert them into small standardized
modules that can be fabricated in
factories this standardization could not
only decrease costs but inherently
increases the reliability and safety as
complexity is removed from the
manufacturing and assembly while
decreasing on-site construction costs
small modular reactors work in much the
same way as regular nuclear plants but
with smaller individual reactors that
can work in expandable modules gradually
increasing the output of a power plant
with cheaper factory made modules rather
than building one large custom designed
nuclear power plant with 1000 megawatts
of electricity capacity making the
reactor smaller also comes with the big
benefit of passive safety a smaller
reactor has more surface area for heat
transfer to occur in proportion to the
volume of material that needs cooling
meaning natural convection Cycles are
sufficient to cool the reactor as the
coolant is heated it rises due to its
lower density establishing a natural
flow pattern that drives the cooling
process smrs are not defined as one type
of nuclear reactor or design rather they
are a family of designs that take
advantage of the miniaturization of the
technology because of this no one SMR is
like the other some use Gen 4 reactors
others use light water reactors
currently over 70 commercial small
modular reactors are being developed new
scale may be the most promising of all
these companies their most recent 77
megawatt module is around 20 meters tall
and 4.5 meters the diameter each of
these modules is lowered into a water
bath and set on seismic isolators this
makes sure that any earthquakes do not
affect the reactor all of the components
needed for the nuclear reaction are
fitted in one steel containment vessel
to create a larger plant multiple
modules are connected together if power
to the reactor is lost control rods fall
automatically in a gravity driven
mechanism and the containment vessel
seals its valves to isolate itself the
water from the core is boiled off as
Steam but stays inside the containment
vessel transferring Heats with the
outside cooling pool the steam condenses
and pools at the bottom of the reactor
vessel creating a natural circulation of
cooling water inside the steel
containment vessel within seconds the
energy and temperature drop drastically
and within a day the thermal power drops
by 90 percent cooling off the last 10
percent over the course of weeks and
while this all sounds great we are
nowhere near Commercial deployment new
scale is by far the most ahead but have
only managed to create a one-third scale
model of their power plant other
countries like Russia China France and
South Korea have also invested in
creating SMR Technologies but have
struggled to find utility customers
without potential customers these
startups will always fail in a
capitalist system even new skill has
been dropped by some utility clients as
their prices seem to have exceeded
expectations this poses a massive
challenge to companies that rely on
large-scale standardized factories to
achieve their key Market advantage to
build the factory they need customers
but they can't get customers without the
factory thousands of reactors will need
to be built before economies of scale
can kick in and in reality the exact
reason traditional nuclear reactors
produce so much electricity is to
benefit from the economy enemies of
scale building a 1000 megawatt reactor
reduces the cost per megawatt and that's
the most important metric in the
electricity Market that's how you get
grid operators to buy your electricity
by making it cheaper new skills original
price point was 55 dollars per megawatt
hour however due to inflation Rising
steel costs development issues and many
delays the costs are now estimated at
100 per megawatt hour in comparison
onshore wind and solar can be as cheap
as 30 dollars per megawatt hour with the
threat of climate change looming over us
we need to ask ourselves can we rely on
a capitalist system to fix a problem
driven by capitalism there is a distinct
possibility that these technologies will
never succeed without Government funding
energy generation is the foundation of
every major world economy and it is in
countries best interest to invest in
these Technologies nuclear energy
provides energy security the U.S is not
alone in trying to develop the
technology China has embarked on the
construction of a functional small
modular reactor project here however
similar to many nuclear Ventures costs
have significantly escalated with the
SMR reportedly being twice as expensive
in terms of cost per kilowatt hour
compared to a traditional large-scale
nuclear plant Canada has formulated a
2020 SMR action plan to help bring down
costs and have invested millions of
dollars into SMR startups developing
these technologies will need vastly more
money than this but it's a step in the
right direction wind and solar are a
game-changing technologies that we could
only have dreamed of being as cheap as
they are today two decades ago but we
need every tool at our disposal to fight
climate change not just to decarbonize
our energy generation but to start
fighting the effects of climate range
population growth and Global
industrialization from increasing demand
for air conditioning water scarcity
driving the need for energy intensive
water desalination to last-ditch efforts
to reverse climate change with carbon
capture energy is the cause and solution
to our problems
the transition from fossil fuels in my
opinion is the most pressing issue
facing Humanity this is an all hands on
deck problem we need our best Minds
working on it and I see it as part of my
responsibility with the platform as
large as mine to inspire the next
generation of Engineers to work on the
solutions where I try to inspire I see
brilliant as the perfect partner for
follow-through for Education the courses
on brilliant are perfect for getting you
prepared for engineering college or for
simply advancing your current career
from Advanced mathematic courses to
computer science they even have courses
on the very Foundation of energy
generation electricity and magnetism
brilliant uses interactive courses that
test your knowledge along the way a
platform designed to teach you difficult
subjects in the most efficient way
possible using visual interactive
examples and they don't impede your
progress when you struggle if you can't
figure out an answer you can open an
in-depth expert the nation and move on
to the next section these are likely the
most universally useful courses to
present and future Engineers but there
are plenty of other courses on brilliant
AI data science neural networks and more
you can get access to those courses
right now and all of brilliant's other
curated interactive courses by clicking
the link in the description and on
screen right now you can get started for
free for 30 days and the first 500
people to do so will get 20 off
brilliant's annual premium subscription
[Music]